[Music] citizens of the reject Nation we are
going to watch Invincible episode three of
season 2 today Gregs and shorts because Greg just
came from the gym that's right reject apparel is
good for any occasion sleeping casual Hangouts
parties family gatherings or going to the gym it
always works joined once again by Aaron Alexander
Aaron the Alexander how are you Aaron Alexander
at Instagram Alexander the realex that is me
Aaron Alexander Aaron Alexander Instagram and
and Tik Tok I Aaron Alexander I'm doing well
today on this this beautiful day how are you
Greg Alba it's the Greg Alba totally promoted
okay whatever how are you the Greg Alba don't
worry about it ladies and Gentlemen please go
ahead leave a like on this video that would be
exceptional be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell because we got episode 4 to
go to as well for next week of season 2 also
thank you to everyone who's joined us on our
patreon especially for invincible that really
means a lot that's where you get the full inat
watch along where you sync with your own copy
of invincible we also cover several shows over
there they're exclusively with highlights and
watch alongs included all righty guys let's do
[Music] it where you going time to push my
baby bird out of the nest it's good thing
I can already fly you going to be okay right
that's cute we going to college already did
you just graduate last episode I promised myself
I wouldn't cry oh this past year has just been
so oh wow we've time jumped a whole year but
college is a fresh start feel like it's a few
months cuz he's just starting College I really
want a clear indicator of the time span here or
else I'm going to think about it the entire
episode give me Clarity show I got your card
from my friend Olga my name is Debbie yeah
yeah yeah no uh sorry no last names Debbie
but Olga told me about you what is this Seance dog
really what are we 12 h does that look crooked to
you yeah very you already have a girlfriend
and you're superhero I on the other hand am
single and have no superpowers and thus
actually have to attempt game well he
can't use his superpowers to get a girl I would
100% Magnum P when it's on the door handle like
so it means go eat a taco or fly to Spain or do
whatever you have to do but don't come in until
the sock is gone respect the sock there's some
stuff out here do it belone to you guys toys uh
they're collectibles who's this dog this an
indie Universe superhero yeah seems like it
some Easter egg which is odd because put in
the comments engage it looks up to that dog
I'm sure it exists in another Multiverse I
think that was a robot uh action figure what
are you doing that wouldn't surprise me within
this universe oh I think they might be um it's
like doctor strange but a dog I don't know what I
was thinking is his name dogor [Laughter] strange
who has sex on the first day of college damn
lots of people probably us for example hey get
it my roommate doesn't arrive until tomorrow
we have the whole place to ourselves uh okay
I mean have they not done it before yeah
have you been saving yourselves definitely
not I bought these oh she knew good good
to have those he would break those he's
Invincible wait you don't have like super
or something do you oh they've never done
it before Oh [__] seems normal wow not
that I would I think it's fine and you
wouldn't accidentally crush me or something
these are very valid questions we never see
them addressed in any comic book show or movie
boys kind of does oh fair you're right you're
right turn off the lights first no Dam
oh my God super powers baby and turn our
attention to the Stars W and a story that
began Generations ago in this missive this
mination on the planet yopa a peaceful and
thriving world the yopin had achieved harmony
with nature and Technology who who's narrating
right now I don't know everything changed in the
blink of an watching how the vites destroyed
them a dark force invaded yopa this when ay
man comes back the yopin that died never
knew who their conquerors were the ones
that lived quickly learned the name Vite yep okay
we bringing it back however the unopen spirit was
UN broken biting their time for decades they
waited for a moment of weakness and rebelled
that'll do no good they still underestimated
their oppressors team vulture might let's
go
ooh they all look the same they're not real
people that's why it's easy some yopin were
able to escape and the promise of a new life
within a generation wa look at a lot of legs
breeding camps on various unopen outposts
to rebuild their population ah neat fadus
the leader of the Coalition of planets invited
them to the planet telesa to join their ranks
so interesting weing this whole backstory yeah
right the Vite campaign has become the scourge
of the Galaxy and We Stand United against it
that's Optimus Prime oh the breeding camps were
also a genetic enhancement program designed
to breed a soldier that could defeat a Vite
in combat are we building up to Allen the results
were not promising until Allan yep yep the super
soldier Allan Allan was trained to be the greatest
fighter the universe had ever known and a opponent
could not be found who didn't fall to his might
love this reintroduction of him was cool they
literally built a hero to defend themselves
Allan still couldn't match even a single Vite
in combat the program was considered a failure
man was made a planetary evaluation officer sent
to discover any being able to defeat him may be
true that Allan was supposed to be keeping tabs
on the planet Ura his mistake led him to Mark
Grayson happy accident love how this feels like
an 80s sci-fi movie I was just thinking it
was feeling like like a Serial you have to
be alien are we completely shifting
Focus this is experimental yeah I'm so down for
it yeah I to see where this goes song always
has great music the show always has great
music data log hello to you too here you
go e what a weird face it's like detached
almost yes I found the right Planet because
it was the wrong planet you already found
before is it still a mistake if it ends up
saving the universe no it's F yes okay I guess
agree or disagree this feels like Star Trek we
need more then good thing I found us one oh Mark
Grayson you warn the Earth Champion that a Vite
lives among his people I love that it's Optimus
Prime it's just this dude his name is Mark and
he's only half Vite that battle Beast no it's
not probably the same race though when he got
his powers all he wanted to do was help other
humans then his father decided it was time to
conquer the planet so they they got in a fight
about it that has not happened since the Great
Purge since the rise of the ALS spark he just
wants to protect his world and Conquer others
in its name no you're being racist give him a
chance even Across the Universe they feel it's
inevitable for years we've been searching for
a hole in the vit's armor Allan is Right vites
never abandon their missions yet one has
I can't get over it but a son defies his
father these are weaknesses love how it looks
like a classic depiction of God you have done
well Alan and given us much to discuss we will
call on you again soon he's playing Optimus par
there is hope for Cybertron after all they have
no idea what this means if there are other Vite
kids out there maybe we can turn them against
their parents too no that just start with Mark
and leave it at that for a while we got one down
we're okay you want me to discover if someone's
betrayed us that's him most valuable asset thank
you sir if there's a mole I'll find them he's the
mole you think he's the mole why would he make
him what a great way to throw someone to hide
in plain sight but to even to make him aware
of the fact that there's a mole why would he
do that to himself Aaron I refuse to believe
I'm wrong even when you bring up a very logical
points I know you weren't suspicious of
anything but let me give you something to
be suspicious about and I'll I'm the person
you should be suspicious of what a weird you
did yes you did you did miss your daddy didn't
you I love how much more layers were getting to
Allen he's actually coming across like badass
did you miss me oh I missed you yeah how much
the most or like yep I knew what this was let's
see if that's true oh yeah oh yeah oh goodness
tentacles time to return to Earth and rejoin
Amber Bennett and Mark Grayson no we just started
getting going let's get freaky with some tentacles
oh I see uh [Laughter] no who to cut to well
um Al Eve the unopen feline he has one large
eye in the center of his head that doesn't
stop him from having all manner of household
Adventures that's like some avatar creature
that air bender just like some hybrid how do
you eat canlock it's disgusting he doesn't
think so it's so sad they're squirming they're
scared oh no this is horrible the food is eating
food that's hilarious The Circle of Life hey
what did Theus want to talk about after the
council meeting look I'm not really supposed
to uh is she the mole I believe she's the mole
now that would be that would be narratively
conflicting I'm supposed to satisfying [Music]
oh what oh what oh no we're meeting them oh
god oh come on Alan I don't know how you're
going to survive this but answer our questions
and we will consider sparing your life you will
tell us everything about your encounter with
the VTR light of earth oh they're after omn
man oh my God are you certain he abandoned his
post oh [__] do they punish him and really
like to know God they're so powerful just slap
like it's nothing this is not good man this is
not good which one was he again you B clops all
kind of look the same to me B clops no damn oh my
God this is awful [Music] no dude [__]
yo what kind of interrogation is this my
God oh my God no his ey oh my God oh my
God what are they doing kill [Music] them
what the hell is going on no tell me this
isn't this isn't our Earth maybe this is
a Multiverse thing maybe this isn't the R
Allen oh this is so sad dude someone has to
repair him they wouldn't they wouldn't
give us that whole thing about the the
mole and and just kill him immediately was so
heartbreaking oh he's alive we don't know if
this is him I'm going guess that is yeah it
is him we don't know it could be a different
one I refuse to believe I'm wrong I still [__]
shot I was like didn't just do that how how did
he survive that that's insane the mole gave
information to V mites okay okay that that
makes sense they once again underestimate the
inopen will to survive there the mole to come
here attack alen at home the vites must know we've
discovered something that scares them you should
get some rest I will watch over him he's the mole
I was going to kill him I was going to kill him
you're right you're [__] right you why would he
tell him there was a mole in the first place what
made you think he was the mole forgive me Alan
got to leave something for the review while Greg
thinks of an answer what already no way no no
that's no this is a mislead has to be yeah we
haven't been back yet yep this ends the Allen part
of the episode the structure on this is so odd and
I love it I'm so here for it this is so strange
the best episode of the season so far oh oh wow
you cheated on me with the immortal that's what
you think happened even if that was true you were
cheating on Eve with me first how does it make it
okay that worked out in your favor The Immortals
like 2,000 years old you know that's what makes
him experienced we are probably the same age I'm
too young for you now I is that it you're just
an [__] well how is that news Fair Point The
Immortals the only person I've ever met who's died
as many times as I have oh [__] but it means
something they feel every death gets it I never
thought of it like that damn hello Chums I'd like
to run while remaining in a stationary location is
that cool beans where are you from for Real where
are you from go ahead shapes Smith I'll just be
over there in a stationary location he does not
understand the concept of a treadmill I set up
this visual feedback system so I could practice
controlling my fear response via meditation and
active thought are you sure that's a good idea
people feel fear for a reason and it's usually a
good reason helps you Keen sense of awareness I
guess you'll find out the hard way have fun next
time you fall off a cliff or [Music] something
can you just remove that part from your brain fear
hasn't just made me use in battle it's prevented
me from doing something else I've wanted to do
for quite some time oh tell her you love her oh
will you go to a movie with me oh sure sure Rudy
uh uh why uh that's cute you became this for her
I know just the way she responded to it she's
like yeah sure why not oh my God you better
give him [__] in the comments for that guys I'm
protecting your ass on that weaponizing an army
now we're not that different from other support
groups excepts to Identity first names only you
aren't required to share till you're ready but
that's why we're all sacrificing a Tuesday nights
you're required to but you know don't waste our
time yeah I wonder if people would even hear her
out if they found out her husband was homy man
you know probably not well they proba they'd have
empathy for her you know once they got to know her
then she revealed it I feel like it be divisive
Mark respond back to your mom I didn't say much
at my first meeting either I can leave you alone
no it's fine I I dropped my son off at college
today empty house yeah it's okay I totally get it
we all do there's a bar down the street some of us
like to go to after group I just figured since it
seems like neither of us wants to go home but no
pressure of course I don't miss you someday you'll
have to tell me all about your childhood oh we're
already seeing a horror movie tonight do you know
if he and Rex are the same voice actor cuz they're
clones you just use different same actor okay two
tickets for midnight Slaughter That's rated R
I see and you need your parents to buy you RR
tickets come back come back as an adult how does a
parent presence change a film suitability for the
underage it's fine they're my kids they can
see the movie how you do that this might be
your first movie but it's not mine you'd be
surprised what people will do for 10 bucks
if this is your first movie What other normal
stuff haven't you done ice cream oh okay Burger
yeah I love this Slice of Life stuff I'm so
endeared by this a good burger and fries is
one of the greatest Pleasures in life yes I'm
discovering that oh my God robot's going to
get fat did you move after your partner passed
away I moved the furniture couldn't afford to
relocate do we know who the partner is I don't
think we do yet I think it's um the green girl
fzy girl part of the Guardians yeah that would
make things complicated her husband killed his
wife yeah it's good to talk with someone who
understands I wish I could tell you it gets
easier but Alana's been gone nearly a year and I
still reach across the bed for her every morning
Alana m I mean yeah C it she was the green
ghost C it yikes she got murdered by that
alien psychopath I didn't know she had a partner
oh he's drinking she wanted to protect [Music]
me woof I'm kind of still screwed up about
what happened to Rick I always imagine we
be here at Upstate together hard CES said he's
doing better man and the grief of this season
for real some capacity hey I bet that's somebody
ready for round two coming ambers omn man evance
just cast a paw over this whole thing Mark
Grayson is that the narrator I think so Mark
Grayson that's awesome who are you why
it is I Seance dog Seance dog Seance
dog isn't real he's a comic book character
Multiverse in your dimension yes but there
exists Myriad other world where dogs
and Magic are as real as the air you
breathe this voice is great open your mind and
let me help you reach the other side hey well
whatever you're doing don't Oh no you're going to
how's no one looking mask bro you don't understand
man what are you doing Mark talk
to him who are you and what do you
want you lied my name is nalot I am from the
planet thraxa my people sent me to plead for
your help okay rumors of the one they call
Invincible have spread like wildfire your
speed your strength you're the only one who
can save our people from the meteor shower
is destroying our world do it Mark how many bug
people are in danger 42 billion damn don't worry
about your classes I'll cover for you somehow
why do you care so much because last time you
didn't want to help someone we both regretted it
but college is everything you can't just go to
some random planet with some random alien are
you insane shut up Cecil a lot of people died
because of me Cecil this is a chance to save lives
billions of them you do anything to help because
of his guilt I need to listen to myself before I
listen to you you your father felt the same way
that's manipulative you're missing the Nuance Cil
how's it going hey come to your window and before
last season he would have to kind of make up some
[__] Happ be there's transparency now I have to
go away for a few weeks to space again A lot of
people are going to die if I don't I'm sorry but
I stop stop never apologize for saving lives
self go be careful always they not said I love
you Amber I um yeah I love you that [__] hung oh
no no no okay I just keep assuming the worst about
women it takes time to heal I can't heal
because my husband's not dead he's gone
because because he murdered Alana and
the other Guardians why would you tell
her that your husband's omn man I wish
I could grieve and move on but I can't
I I can't I wish he was dead too oh my
God no you shouldn't come back to the
group yep wouldn't be a safe space with you
[Music] there that hurts Invincible huh we're
here W time freaky colorful really purple the
Grimace Design This Wait what exactly about
this planet needs saving we're the meteors what
made what the ones that are killing billions oh
yeah those meteors don't worry the Monarch will
explain all oh [__] don't trust him he started
this interaction with deception and then you
followed him to space anyway may I present
Invincible of Earth is it omn man I don't know who
are we expecting is it a different vulture M hello
son it's been a while [Music] oh [Music] Dad
this crazy the hell's he doing there right
what the hell oh wow damn what a reveal what a
crazy reveal that was such a long post credit
scene is there no more they normally do like
the the immediate after I guess they kind did
it earlier [__] he see episode one of season
1 did this similar thing Rob Delaney episode one
of season 1 did a similar thing but it was only
like 10 and 15 minutes this was like the end of
the Allen chapter and then they just went into it
yeah it's weird it kind of like snaps your brain
into like focusing more right CU make you think
it's over it's like there's something important
yeah wow yeah oh man that was so good God but you
know what else is really good if you go to www.re
naations shop.com and they travel through space
here so much they're like the space babies of the
Galaxy you know what I mean or you know like this
he has to protect people like our child protection
services with Pedro and grou there together and we
also got like who influences the influencers com
book inspired we got a whole bunch of other te's
as well that we absolutely love like America's
ass and you know we just a whole bunch of things
but it is one of the best ways my favorite way to
support the channel thank you to all bought tees
if you buy a tea tag us on social media I want to
I'll make sure to like add you to the stories and
stuff thank you guys so much Aon Aon Greg we got
13 minutes to talk oh man so many things so many
things have happened in this wonderful 45ish to
49 minute episode the speed of your talking is
amazing right now speed up like koi you want to
talk like five we can be quality efficient here
okay episode really good loved the beginning with
Allen uh got to explore more of him I thought Seth
Rogan did a fantastic job he kind of disappeared
into this character shout out Optimus Prime he
was really cool too you called being the mole
I don't know how you did that that was that was
crazy I was like why would he reveal himself to
be the mole making him suspicious and then be the
mole I don't know I don't know shit's weird uh but
that fight was really brutal in the beginning
and yeah I think all the things that are that
were set up from the end of last season are now
coming to fruition which makes me a little not
not confused but like curious as to like how's
the stuff with the Multiverse going to tie into
this stuff because we didn't even really touch it
or address it in this episode also where was Eve
this entire episode we didn't really talk about
that but I think the stuff that I did really like
was us getting to explore some of the characters
that we really got attached to and got to know in
the first first season got to spend more time with
Rex and duplicate and robot and monster girl and I
was really invested in those things in the first
season so I'm happy that we're finally getting
those characters some light in this season and
yeah some really interesting cool reveals you
know with with omn man at the end there I was like
was not expecting that and I I feel really bad for
Debbie I feel really bad for Debbie because she
opened up was vulnerable clearly distraught about
all the things that have happened and he's
he was just like nah get out of here you're
trash just like don't come around here like you
you don't to see this woman as geving too like
clearly affects her as well so yeah I everyone's
going through it you know whether it be om not
omn man whether it be duplicate going through the
grieving process and connecting with Immortal but
the fact that they've died multiple times and kind
of like the grief and like trauma that comes with
that or you know just the stuff with Debbie and
we didn't really get too much into Mark's grief
this episode but clearly his guilt uh from all of
the Fallout of what happened last season permeates
throughout all of this season so far and yeah
I enjoyed it I really did what about you man
what you think yeah was good man good good stuff
everything's good everything's good everything's
good everything's great yeah I think that the
the episode was structured in a way that was so
different than any other episode of invincible
and I really appreciate when they deviated from
it because it it leads to an element of everything
feeling unexpected you know like to go from this
time Jump where Mark is in college which again is
like a that's such a superhero kind of plotline of
someone trying to balance it out very Peter Parker
es and you're like I don't I don't know what the
point of view even [__] doing this really
is honestly man like what you why why everyone
know a college on a broke anyway right yall have
student loan debts right shout out student loan
debt shout out student loan debts shout out the
few who become really successful after college
no go to school get educated stay educated um go
to education for go for the education but anyway
um yeah go that plot line and then as you talked
about with the grief that sort of cast a PA over
this entire episode but what was really cool about
this was how they really expanded the universe
like it seems like this section of invincible the
first season was very much like focused in this
one they're opening up it's still focused but in
a different kind of way where they're opening up
the doors for what is really possible within
this universe like we got multiverses we got
these different planets you got different space
exploration I thought it was really cool how you
can take an episode where you take a certain
chunk out of it focus on this completely other
realm with thus with Allen and I find myself like
so invested in that that I didn't even want to cut
away from it I wanted to just stay there deal with
the plot of like whatever conspiracies happening
and then they even open up the door of course
with the vulture mites as well where they're like
interrogating Allen they're whooping his ass and
pretty much like nearly kill the guy and they're
also on the hunt for omn man and they're it seems
like they they need to make a decision on whether
or not they punish or execute omn Man based off
of him not fulfilling his mission and then to tie
it in to the very end of this where it looks like
omn man has decided to be like a he's a fugitive
he's escaped like this is just a theory haven't
read the comics so that's what makes a lot of this
really fun as we have no idea what direction it's
going but then when you go to omn man at the very
end the impression that it gives you is like
did he reform in some way because he couldn't
follow through with do uh the Domin do dominating
Earth that now he has become some benevolent ruler
because everything seems so peaceful everything
and he is the ruler of that planet but there's a
sense of ethereal jovial kind of resonating
throughout that entire planet wait a minute
this is not the omn manulera of cool about seeing
the multiverses at the beginning as you and seeing
how vites dominate like Allen's Planet you see
what kind of rulers the vites are I'm like this
is not the way a Vite rules right you know so like
how how much has he changed is it is it an act is
there some bigger planet like what what door is
it opening up and he still wants to connect with
his son you know and like they also seem really
threat in the vites by him having a son you know
did he really have a SE they said something about
like having another seed or something like that
you know yeah something to that effect yeah it's
I want to watch my words here because really we'
getting a lot of demonetization on stuff like
H with a lot randomly in the past week so I'm
trying to watch my language here especially uh
but a lot of this seemed to deal with sexuality
this episode you know what I mean like between
Paul and uh between Mark and uh amber even Allen
and then also like the idea of you know omn man
having a kid and like the seed carrying on like
there there's a sort of element there that I did
and then even like going to college and stuff like
the whole thing with William which I thought was
also a really great thing to bring back around
is like they're not dropping the ball on anything
here they're not dropping um any plot line just to
like they're not sacrificing character development
for jokes or Whimsy or to keep the fun going
apparently a lot of audiences are okay with for
certain properties but for this they're for this
one they they bring it back in a way that where
that Nuance just is so felt like with like with
William bring I'm like thank thank God they did
that like you know that was such an important that
was an impactful episode last season and they they
brought it back around and it shows that William
just not like all right I'm over it I'm going
to have fun with every guy hang you know I can
bang or something like that you know and still
affecting him it's everything's still affecting
them and and then um whatever Corner they're
painting Debbie into is just completely Bleak and
harrowing on all fronts you know that it it seems
so real too that they would blame the I mean this
guy has a very biased subjective take because his
wife was directly murdered by omn man and he need
and they don't have omn man to blame because omn
man's not around right so you know and it's it's
we've seen it happen with people who marry like
a serial killer and they don't know it you should
have known and they get blamed you know and so I
like that realistic element of Debbie just just
trying to find grief she's trying to grief she's
trying to move on that sense of loss of like it'
be easier to grieve if he was dead but there's
also this fear of unknown that he might actually
come back so how can I really get over it and on
top of that when I try to open up I'm just going
to get blamed and shunned because I married that
guy you know and it makes you fear for debie who's
just trying to keep it together yeah I think it's
as you were talking I was I was kind of listening
to some of the the points you're bringing up about
like just kind of listening to some of it yeah
yeah you know just some of it kind of like Zone
and [__] but no no I definitely agree I agree
with your your sentiment about about and like the
path that she's going down and yeah the the fact
that she didn't really see any of this coming
and she didn't ask for any of this but I think
the the thing that kind of percolated my my brain
the the most as you're talking is like the the
still Loring effects of omn man I know that we're
kind of talking about like damn this Show's like
really missing omn man like where's omn man at and
I think they chose a perfect time to reintroduce
that character into the show because we have now
been in this state of like people being paranoid
both on Earth and intergalactically of Mark and
his intentions and we've seen from the beginning
of the Season that in other universes him and his
dad team up so now we're seeing an omn man that
can't go back to Earth who also can't go back
to vmite so he's just like this dude who still
loves his son and now he's two galaxies away and
they're going to reconnect so like what does that
reconnection look like are they going to rekindle
their relationship obviously Mark is going to have
some strong feelings about that is omn man going
to be able to be reformed is that something that's
in the cards is that something that interests
him is that something that the show even can not
sustain but like I don't know what what would that
look like and does that cause further mistrust if
he does form a relationship with his dad and if
he's forming a relationship with his dad at this
point in the show how is that going to affect the
things that's going on with this new multiversal
villain and is he going is that guy get like the
wrong idea about the fact that omn and Mark are
now reunited again because those two as a force
is [__] deadly to uh the the survival or the
the health of Earth or maybe it's a manipulation
Ploy with that omn man is playing some type of
bigger game here or if it's not even omn man
what if it's just another shape shifting but
that would be that wouldn't be satisfying we
got the shape shifting element there we have
and then oh and also the sexuality too the the um
re flod and duplicate and all that yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I think they just bring a lot of depth
to everyone's getting like an extra pound of death
depth here which I think is so cool like I I love
seeing Rudy and uh monster girl whatever her name
is I know it's not monster girl I love seeing
them hang out with each other and just those like
poignant Slice of Life things where he is really
learning about Humanity in a way like he's he's
understanding human emotion like he keeps trying
to control it in the most analytical sense and
finding weaknesses and things from having been so
detached for so long and he finds himself pulled
to certain feelings of love and then other little
things that bring the most Joy like the taste of
a good burger you know yeah uh I think there's so
many great I I love this episode a lot I thought
it was a really really great episode I was very
much hooked from beginning to end and watching the
development like Amber Mark as well um everything
about it that was excellent yeah I wonder what the
trajectory of Amber and Mark's relationship is
and like are they going to stay together for the
entirety of the show how is that going to affect
them because like we've been in granted they're
having this open communication dialogue now but
how long can that form of their relationship be
sustainable true cuz she's not a super hero he
always has to go off you know he'll outli her
he'll outli her yeah he's he's he's a Vite you
know he's going to age a lot slower than her so
these I think these are things that are going to
come to head eventually yeah so I'm curious to
see where those things go but yeah it was a great
episode overall loved it guys what would you rank
that episode um I give it like a 10 out of 10 for
me I really love the hell out of that episode guys
I would say the same yeah that was excellent best
epis of the season so far absolutely undeniably
and Man shows up at the Answer Man shows up I
might get some views on this he's going in the
thumbnail yeah right away instantaneously thumb
yeah not even we're not even in title video omn
man's back inin episode three we're just really
small in the corners guys leave your thoughts down
below thank you so much for being here be sure to
subscribe and click that notification Bell and H S
with a what's going on guys so there's only a few
I keep messing that up every time I say it there's
only so many days left in the month there is one
day left in the month so we have to shout out at
least two patrons for Patron the day sh to make
sure we are getting our obligations taken care
of G and uh today I am going to choose to throw
in Michael B and Danny pank hey so Michael be
let's start with you omn media Michael band cakes
really helpful behind the scenes with the channel
has obviously collabed here done several videos
with him he's did just one with John recently for
Mission Impossible right often help each other
out with advice sometimes super late at night
uh it just overall has been this incredible Gem
and has been one of our like OG patrons for the
longest time and refuses to unpledge even though
I've said please stop your making making things
awkward this is a conflict of interest uh but he
continues to do so and I think the with the goal
in mine is that whatever we pay him when he does
a collab with us that he's just getting all that
money back eventually but I don't think he has
I don't even think he's close to breaking even
that's why he's on YouTube is someday breaking
yeah so I appreciate uh everything you do man
you've been a absolutely amazing indominable
spirit in our lives and Danny pancakes I Don't
Know Jack sh about you uh I just wanted to say
um thanks for pancakes because they're delicious
I I don't get to meet eat them that often and
I I you know I have them with butter and syrup
like every other human being you unless you're
one of those freaks who's like I want a syrup
on my pancakes like dry P some people like a
dry pancake and I think that's kind of gross
I don't know what kind of pancake eater you are
Danny pancakes it's not Danny pancakes and syrup
I'll tell you that yeah that's true man there's
no syrup in that last name so could just be the
D sford dry pancake on Danny and then you know
Danny I have an uncle Danny and uh he's never
done anything illegal to me so I like my uncle
Danny and he likes pancakes and he likes pancakes
very much so with strawberry syrup actually and
and you know like Danny Rand is easily the most
underrated character in all Netflix MCU H so you
know like pink things saying you know like Dany
and pancakes those are just a great combination to
me so I just want to say thank you for somehow I
had more to say about during your segment than I
did someone who I really know and talk to on the
phone but I there are just so many great Danny's
so great pancakes you know I mean like if Danny
ocean was ever seen in a breakfast time scene
Rusty would be eating pancakes there's so many
correlations like yeah I could thank you for
just pledging and for being here for as long
long as you have been that's boring you get that
from any patreon page we just got to really focus
on like why you chose the name Danny pancakes you
know there's another Danny I know is Daniel last
name Melgar since he was a baby now he's like one
of the smartest people I've ever known yeah he's
Jack of many tra Danny how much how much has Danny
pledged to us over time oh uh uh a a fat stack of
flap Jacks I'll tell you that 190 that's amazing
man dude amazing let's see if we can get this to
2000 that's a lot 2000 I believe in stepping stone
goals so we go from $190 to $2,000 let's get you
up to two grand all right just stick around
stick around you got a ways to go $2,000 man
you're dedicated believe in it appreciate you oh
[__] know you've been with us for a long time
cting fat stats May Since 2021 yeah God damn D you
been here a long ass time Hell's yeah since yeah
dude how many months is that that's a I'm trying
to make another pancake joke and I don't have one
for this bit but April no man we'll figure it out
hold on hold on a second okay hold on hold on a
sec if someone has been a has has given me $190
in total starting from April 2020 to nov 2023
how much is that per month that this information
is this is great we can see the you know at what
hold on a second let's unusual activity what what
like no one asked this question yeah what's going
on this is not that they're like what a strange
question to ask me I'm not asking you to like
speculate on like the world's bank or something
like that stupid AI tell me what I want to know
yeah okay I so he's average $6.3 per month okay so
what is 2,000 divided by 613 okay so all right or
how many more months would it take to get to how
many more months will it take to get he gets to
$2,000 um so don't worry Danny I'm going to get
you an answer I know I know you're you're really
trying to like set some goals here yeah yeah
yeah but and and I mean not that to suggest
that you should stop after 2000 I'm just saying we
want to what the hell is wring really doing with
some hold on this is some real complex math we
could have figured this out in the time that this
is taking it's really annoying math um it would
take about 296 more months okay that's at least
a couple years so if there's 52 months in a year
wait no is I mean there 12 months 52 months 12
months in the longest Year my life so 12 let's
go two it's 24 56 uh I guess that would be uh
that would be like uh 20 something years right
something like that yeah they be there in like
20 something years and then 27 yeah what's
what's 296 divided by 12 no I can figure it
out no it's said 29 by 12 that's not how the
math goes right it's 296 divid by $6 oh sure
cuz it's how many months yeah 26 divid by six
oh I'm trying to figure out the years yeah oh
oh my bad uh so we need to figure out the years
okay let me do no I'm going to figure this out
John Jesus Christ you had six and a half minutes
last time going to get us to eight all right so
uh all right Danny pancakes don't worry I got
your cover all right so okay 12 and that 24 56
what's 12 divid what's 56 divided by uh 12 uh
uh oh God uh is that right math yeah yeah yeah
what's 565 by 12 it's a 12 * 4 is 48 12 * so
yeah so it be like 24 and a half months okay
all right pull the calculator correct four and
a half years I mean this 296 uh uh 296 divided
by 12 24 24 and A2 months baby66 almost 24 and
a half yeah dude all right well let's hope the
patreon let's hope patreon's still around by then
couple years from now patreon.com is still around
it's the biggest website on Earth it can't go away
all right Danny you know what you got to do and uh
Michael um I'll send you a text message we'll
talk off camera and Shout you out in a person
[Music] life